so tonight ask yourself why is joe biden
not standing up to our adversaries
around the globe why is he emboldening
and enabling them
all across the globe joe's rewarding
vladimir putin with
nordstrom 2 the pipeline giving putin
more leverage over our allies in western
europe
russia did pay his son a lot of money
joe is silent on china threatening our
military
and china threatening anyone who stands
in the way of what they're calling the
reunification of taiwan
hunter made a lot of money there too joe
isn't standing up to
the iranians as they're now enriching
uranium once again
making proxy payments to terrorist
groups continuing to be the
largest state sponsor of terror and
what's joe's answer he lifts sanctions
and forces south korea to pay the
iranian mueller 7 billion dollars
to free a south korea flag ship seized
by iran
and now there's this because we're
learning more tonight about how an
iranian-american journalist
in new york who has been courageous and
staunch in her criticism of the regime
was the target of a kidnapping plot for
iranian operatives in this country
charged with conspiring to kidnap
and that is a fifth person has been
arrested for financing the
operation according to the indictment
these iranian
intelligence assets scheme to try and
lure her to
a foreign country kidnap her ship her
off to iran
she's also the victim of extensive
surveillance and stalking including
their video feed from her home but
tonight she's speaking out and she's
standing strong and is calling on the
biden administration to stand up to
the muellers in iran and calling on the
biden administration to not seek a deal
that emboldens the iranian
uh regime here now journalist author
masih
alinajad well first you're very
courageous um
and we'll pray for your safety and i
mean that tell us what's going on
first of all thank you so much for
having me um i want to actually
start from what i've been witnessing in
the streets
today today i've been giving interview
to fox news and cnn
and then as soon as i walk out from the
buildings
people just american people were really
kind with me they recognized me in the
streets they hugged me
some of them saying god bless you some
of them saying that we are glad that
you're safe
it brought tears to my eyes but that
shows america
they care about human rights they care
about their
fellow people and um fox news and cnn
both
when they saw that i was on their
surveillance i i'm actually
uh not feeling safe not feeling good
both with different agenda with
different views
they both cared about the story this is
what i want
from biden's administrations because
eight months ago when the fbi came to my
house
and told me that i'm not safe here in
america because
the intelligence service hired a private
investigator in new york actually they
taking photos of my private life
photos of my step-children photos of my
husband photos
of myself in my garden i was shocked and
i couldn't
believe it i i left my homeland and now
i'm like yeah
do you feel safe now look i have to say
that i am under
fbi's protection but as far as the
islamic republic is in power
not only me no one is safe no one right
now that i'm talking to you the u.s
citizens are in prison just because the
government took them hostage and using
them like bargaining chips
so i want by then administrations to be
strong
take an action because this dummy
republic is acting like
isis i said take house took hostages
they beheld people the islamic republic
do the same
mossy we pray for your safety and your
family safety
and uh you're very brave to speak out
and you're right
this is the number one state sponsor of
terror hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else